(instrumental music)
- [Narrator] This is Garret.
A Sandhill crane.
If it wasn't for the
Maryland Zoo in Baltimore,
he probably wouldn't be here today.
Garret was found wandering
around a Home Depot parking lot
before being rescued by the zoo.
Scattered throughout Western
and Central North America,
it is incredibly rare to see
them as far east as Maryland.
In the winter, they migrate south,
all the way down to Northern Mexico.
Tall, gray, and slender,
Sandhill cranes have long legs and necks.
Their large wingspan make
them incredibly skilled
soaring birds.
They breed and forage in
open fields and wetlands
and can often be seen
visiting farmer's fields
on the hunt for leftover seeds.
While their population has rebounded
in the last few decades,
loss of habitat and climate change
are still looming threats.
This is the Sandhill crane.